this player just joined in-game credits
Worth 22
000 in real life that is a lot of
guacamole a lot of the Green in the game
Eve online there is a corporate share
system if you've never heard of Eve
online you don't have to know the game
to understand that it is the Microsoft
Excel of gaming it's like Wall Street in
space this level of criminality is
unprecedented even on Wall
Street Reddit user flam Hill one on r
slash Eve to discuss how he managed this
mind-blowing Heist which he dubbed
operation yours is mine so our boys
snuck in and gained membership then flam
transferred his shares and triggered a
vote for a new CEO there were two votes
guess who voted so this is how Liberty
dies no one from the corporation noticed
and then flam fired the board of
directors he emptied the corporate
wallet and got away with it scot-free
it's your first time being around
one great